what up guys welcome back to another
episode of get close and this time we
got jason richardson back again stay
rich in the house be rich and be a
legend and you guys have submitted a
bunch of questions some might be
comfortable oh good so it might be
uncomfortable i don't know we tried
making him uncomfortable in the last
episode if you missed that please check
it out um and he was real smooth about
it you were trying to throw him on the
bus a couple of times it never happened
no we just
jason just said that baseball players
aren't real hey man
all right so we have some fan submitted
questions we got a ton of questions so
sorry if i missed your question i did my
best um first thing first one of our
friends bee choi you guys know beach
homie belief um he is a huge fan of you
and he just wanted to throw it out there
how much he's a fan of you and all he
wanted to ask was how does it feel being
a bay area legend exclamation
exclamation exclamation
i think it's amazing um i think the bay
area has the best sports fans period hey
they are very knowledgeable they love
their teams um
just to go through the history of all
the people that have been through the
bay area and have people say stuff like
that just make me feel like really good
yeah and you know i never really
accomplished a lot of things in my
career but just having that love from
the bay area made me know that i did
something right in my career yeah oh
that's beautiful that's awesome yeah
there's something about bay area people
i love we're from socal yeah we're now
in nevada but we're originally so cal
people and we don't like socal people
we enjoy bay area people they just have
like this different vibe
it's a great vibe yeah it is it feels
like they're like
a little bit more open-minded yeah
they're empathetic and i don't know just
feels like a realness yeah
exactly
exactly okay
uh by christian king favorite dunk you
did and favorite dunk someone else did
is that dunk contest dunk or just
anytime however you want to take the
question you know what i think that for
me it was the dunk contest in the 2000
2003 dunk contest it was my last dunk i
needed something big to try to win it
um and gilbert who are you up against i
was going against uh desmond mason okay
uh gilbert arenas
he could never do all these crazy dunks
but he had all these ideas that i should
do i was like his little puppet hey you
should do this and i'm like okay
but he told me about it throw it up in
the air and take between your legs
and i was like we i did it one time in
practice and i couldn't do it i said i
know when i get to the dunk contest my
drill is gonna be rushing i get this
dunk
and so it's on the line i throw it up i
do the between less dunk it was so sick
all my peers went wild when i saw my
peers one while i know i did something
was crazy but the crazy fact about that
dunk i could never do it again
ever seriously wow i couldn't do that
dunking i mean i've been at like
basketball games or even at your house
like every wherever it was at basketball
camps the kids when i was younger oh can
you do a dunk and they want me to do
that dunk i could never finish it i was
just it's just i did it one time ever in
my life and that was it what if they
lower it to nine foot feet oh yeah
um it is my the favorite dunk by
somebody else um to this day i feel like
is the greatest dunk ever it was by
aaron gordon
um he jumped over the mascot yeah he was
sitting like this in the air wow i don't
think people are alone no yes i don't
believe people know how high he had to
be off the ground because that mascot is
like
six five with the
big old orlando magic thing wow and he
jumped over that over like with his ass
like literally that was that's like the
craziest dunk i've ever seen ever i
think that was the best dunk ever i
think he got cheated at that dunk
contest no disrespect to zach levine
but that was the greatest dog i've ever
seen wow that was actually one of the
follow-up questions and yes okay you
answered the zack levine thing that was
amazing um okay so what was the most
annoying team to play against
ah san antonio
so bart was so boring about it they were
so good and efficient and it was like
give it to tim duncan oh
tony parker's the fastest player on the
court yeah i remember that you're so
sweet
bruce
like i hate playing against you guys
i love it but it was so funny um i
remember i just told a friend the other
day
it's crazy how like these the superstars
like guys like you know tim duncan yeah
for example
um we're playing against these guys and
we're in san antonio
and i go up and i barely get a dunk on
him like it was like a baby like
fingertip dunk
and it was a big part of the game but
it's like okay it wasn't like nothing
like a poster but he was in it yeah
we played in golden state like two
months later and i go up and try to dunk
on him and he was like not this time
you're not
[ __ ] ducking on me this time this is
tim duncan everybody don't think he cuts
yeah yeah [ __ ] dunking on me this
time
and i'm like
what are you talking about
and then when like after the game i'm
still like bamboozled white i'm not
ducking on i said he remember me trying
to like this baby fingertip dunk on him
and he remember it two months later and
make sure he blocked that dog
but they said it was a boring team to
play against that's dope that he was
thinking about you guys for two months
for two months it was weird
i wish there were microphones on the
court
because i know people like to talk [ __ ]
yeah who
likes to talk the most [ __ ] you think
you don't have to say that uh what
they're saying gary payton was the the
gay people uh by far he was the biggest
[ __ ] target ever like as soon as he
comes on the course
it was just part of the intimidation
in the in the nba you
everybody know it's only like a handful
of guys that really want to fight yeah
and i mean you just let them talk
who uh can the sideline
uh spectators can they hear it
oh yeah and the refs can hear it too
yeah everybody can hear it have you ever
seen like a ref laugh like crack up oh
yeah i see laughs
some of the things people say is pretty
it's pretty funny is some of them just
like man that's just
disrespectful what what's something like
that a ref would call like you can't say
that or
i mean uh
it's pretty much it's no whole bar
seriously oh you can say whatever you
want i feel like it's [ __ ]
let me certain words you know the n word
i mean for black guys tony but if a
white guy said that ref would throw him
out i see uh the f word for you know
sexual orientation they get thrown out i
see i remember a guy called a ref dad
and he threw him out oh
why would you call the ref that that's
no good well the ref was gay though yeah
he he ended up coming out later and
saying that he was gay oh at the time
nobody knew it
was so he probably didn't even mean it
like
yeah yeah yeah
i see yeah he didn't mean it like that
because at the time nobody everybody
kind of
thought about what he was
but then later on years later he came on
and said he was but i think at the time
i was like oh hell no you know
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i feel like it all should just kind
of go right because it's all like a
mental game yeah it is like you're
trying to get under someone's skin and
nobody's going to fight i'm sorry we're
we're the fake tough guys at nba
like hey but it's a handful of guys
there's some guys that will throw a
punch yeah me one of them
if you push me to that level i'm a nice
guy but if you push me to that level uh
i got a little mean streak in me but the
majority of nba guys are not fighting i
mean you're one of six yeah you kind of
have to have that yeah and i have a lot
of cousins too so
i had to defend for myself
um okay uh what is your favorite kobe
bryant memory or story
oh man
again i was just telling somebody this
story the other day um you know kobe was
the type of guy that just came back
every year better he was just always
trying to find the edge on you
and i remember when you hear he came
back he was shooting every shot left
hand when he post up i'm like what the
hell like you're right-handed like you
shooting left-handed wow so it was maybe
my fifth or sixth year in the in the
league and kobe comes up to me and uh
right before the game you know you
handshake how you doing but this time he
was like how you doing and he was like
feeling on my bike like give me a pat
down
just to see if you were working out no
he was feeling for body armor because
that was the first era where guys would
get like real protector cages like these
stuff on their elbows to protect
themselves yeah so he was filling my
body to see if i had ripped it because
it was like guys again this stuff and so
he was feeling if i had it on i didn't
first play the game he gets the ball bow
i literally did it
i was like this dirty [ __ ]
like he's trying to get an edge on me oh
that's awesome so for every time i
played kobe bryant and it was only just
only word you know when i went to the
east coast it was two times when i was
on the west coast team you know that was
for sure
i bought a body armor when i played kobe
because
he couldn't throw an elbow at me it was
just like it was just so crazy how his
competitive edge was he was just trying
to find any was he saying what's up to
the whole team like that everything no
but he knew he was saying to the person
that he know was guarding oh and then
the next guy that was coming in for me
to guard him
hey man hit him on the back he was
checking to see if you had his you know
it was just it was just basically these
tank tops they had like
like little padding about this thick
yeah just to help you for you know like
bruising bruises they had them for your
knees they have for your elbow but most
guys
hips and stuff like that but that was
just him he just tried to get a
competitive edge man is that normal now
everyone has a little bit about it like
a lot of guys do it now because it
prolongs your career prolongs your
career but i mean not many guys throw
elbows a lot guys wear the hip pad ones
because you fall a lot yeah and so it
will protect you from getting the bone
bruise on your hips and stuff and i
started wearing more of the tights
instead of the only when i played kobe i
wore the
hair protector
she's the elbow thrower right here am i
yeah
in our company so in la we had a comedy
production company and after our work
day we used to all just go out and just
play basketball it doesn't matter if
you're if you know how to play or not
it's just fun like fun bonding time and
she played volleyball she didn't play
basketball okay um so she doesn't really
good on the offense side but on the
defense side oh boxing now yeah she was
athletic she has like court iq she
understands where the ball scores she
can anticipate and she would just be
wailing
too yeah
[Laughter]
all right um how does someone work on
the mindset of a champion
oh wow cause you said you were born with
it so now you kind of have to go back a
little bit to see how you can uh i mean
it just um the mindset of a champion in
my opinion is doing whatever it takes to
win
like sometimes it's sacrificing
you know certain things
and coming to sports it's like
i might have to sacrifice me taking
shots because like somebody else on the
team that could do better shots or
oh
so even like a little bit of
selflessness for the selfish win this
was whatever the team need for the
ultimate goal wow and i think when you
have that that mentality especially if
you have a really good team
um
you could go a long way
my year in phoenix we played against san
antonio i wish we'd won a championship
in that team
we're up big we're in san antonio it's
it's it's game three
and we're we're in a tight race with
them the auto star is me steve nash and
mike started my grant hill we're on the
bench wow and our benches in there
literally got it going and you know
coach alvin um gentry came up to us like
hey you guys won't go back in he's like
no
they're they're literally crushing them
crushing it don't go
and it was like this from you know hall
of famers yeah and all-star guys
realizing that our bench is carrying us
through this game that we're not going
back and we didn't go back in the rest
of the game and they end up winning the
game by 15 points
wow
i mean it was a tie game and they just
caught fire man it was just like it was
special to see that
we all gave up something for the
betterment of the team and um we ended
up winning that game and won the next
game with the western conference final
and ran into some guy named kobe and got
our ass
no that is dope i mean you were also
saying in the previous episode about
like um you know when you i think it was
your freshman year in college you were
out partying have a really good time and
then you saw like your star player like
your star team player uh not doing that
and you were like that's it i'm cutting
it out yeah and that that year we won a
championship
and it was crazy because he always told
me um when i was getting recruited by
michigan state i used to come up there
and watch the games and kind of practice
and he told me like i was a junior in
high school he's like you come here we
win the championship
like what
and he promised me that he's like you
come here we're going to win the
championship we need you and then my
senior year
when i committed he said i guarantee we
win the championship you are missing
peace
wow like he was like a big brother to me
like when i first came in the locker
room he was like mateen cleaves he was
like where are you sitting at i said i
don't know you're locker right next to
mine
and it was just like a big brother
atmosphere and he just took me under his
arm and that's so progress is history i
think for you more so um because like in
the please listen to the previous
episode it's so good uh in the previous
episode you were talking about how like
you know you were like i didn't i don't
know why my fans are like the way they
are with me and why they're so like
devoted and passionate about me you're
like i didn't i didn't win anything
right like what still kept you going
forward and being like nah like i'm not
stopping those that fan base it's
literally that that fan base when i was
in golden state
um
you know we were still averaging
15 16 000 fans which is crazy for a
losing team we had like losing streaks
of 10 games in a row
but you could just feel their hunger
like they just wanted us to play hard
for me it was like i have to go do this
you know these some of these fans are
paying their hard-earned dollars to come
and watch me play and you know i took
this escort from jordan's book where he
said he would find somebody in the
raptors
and he'll he'll look at him and like
this might be their only chance to ever
see michael jordan
so i'm playing for that person and so i
took that mentality like i looked way up
in the nosebleed like okay that person
in this area might be the only time they
ever see me play and i'll go out there
and give it everything i had
wow shout outs to the bay area man
that's so cool because i remember
growing up in l.a clippers were our
losing team yeah
and they didn't we didn't have those
tickets would be like seven bucks i know
so you don't really have to pay
that's how they wasn't golden state it
was free but now it's crazy because i
talked to the ghost state fans it's like
man i didn't really have to come to the
games i could bring my wife my kids and
pay like 75 dollars he said 75 only pay
for parking now oh yeah it's just crazy
i mean but that's you know the success
of that team and it's just happy because
you know those fans they deserve all
that because it was some bad years there
yeah a lot of bad years yeah you're a
true champion man yeah um okay speaking
of the current warriors right now how do
you feel about the current warrior squad
i mean as long as you got steph clay and
draymond
you can't go wrong with those guys but i
mean those guys are there i think
they'll be lifelong warrior i mean
warriors um but the young group of guys
they got you know they got moody they
got kaminga they got um
uh
jordan poole i mean
uh juan toscano uh i mean they got a
nice young group of guys yeah so
um you know with those days coming with
stuff and clay and draymond become older
man and they're getting older every year
that's just life
um they got a good young group of guys
that come in to fill their place and
they're playing well i know they hit a
bump in a row but that's just a matter
of time before those guys gel back
together and i think be one of the teams
would be a dark horse to win a
championship this year
dang calling it what do you think about
uh your first impressions on steph curry
like
so
when when i got into basketball it was
like kobe and iverson era right so like
that aggressive driving to the basket
like that was like the style
and so that was kind of like what made
it like i guess more exciting for me
then out of nowhere you got like this
guy that's like shooting like two three
four feet behind the three point line
but it's just sinking them all day and
they're just like okay like
this guy's like you gotta put a stop to
this you know like
did he do you feel like he brought on
like
a new era of basketball that was oh yeah
he definitely changed the game and it's
crazy i did an interview
a few months ago right before he broke
the record um a radio station in the bay
area called me
and somebody went through my my tweets i
was like holy smokes they went back a
long time ago so i think stuff been in
the league for 10 years i either don't
tweet a lot or they wouldn't wait
i don't know which one
but um when i first came when he first
came in the league we had the same
trainer and so my trainer was like hey
man i'm bringing this kid he's from
davidson he's going to get drafted he's
top 10 pick start bringing whatever
we work out i literally tweeted out hey
he got he ended up getting drafted by
golden state
i said hey bury your fans y'all gonna
have one of the greatest players to come
i literally said this one years ago
and when i saw this kid he wasn't big
but his skill level was unreal and the
way he shot the ball so he he definitely
transcended the game because now it's a
definitely shooting game yeah um but
it's amazing what he does and what he
has done for the game because you know i
think it made a lot of people more
attractive to basketball because
when you think of basketball you think
big tall athletic guys duncan all that
but now
the small guy that could shoot the ball
could play basketball so i think he
really was a transgender and like making
the just open up the game to the world
because everybody go play basketball
because he's not the biggest guy but
he's shooting the ball the best yeah he
found his own strength yeah that's so
cool yeah
all right um do you have any rituals
that you must perform before a game and
why
uh the biggest one during the national
anthem i pray this just pray for you
know protection from me my teammates and
the other team that nobody gets hurt
because you know injuries is part of the
game and um
you know before the praying part i'm
just i'm superstitious i have certain
spot on the floor that i shoot from um i
just shoot there because that's your
spot that's my spot i mean i know if i
miss a couple of shots i go to that spot
because that's why i've been sitting
there for 10 minutes shooting at this
one spot and so i kind of get
superstitious with those two things that
i have to do at every game that's it
there's no specific shoe there's no
specific socks did you have anyone that
had to wear like the same old socks or
something that was just so nasty yeah
some guys had some weird things uh you
know rubber bands they have to wear the
same shoes same socks
dude yeah i mean but most of them
watched it was like it was nothing
really
funky like that
my teammates were like that but i had
certain guys that had to you know get
their ankle taped at a certain time or
oh wow um a quick story about
gilbertines this is the my best story
about him gilbert's one of my good
friends
um he had a terrible first half we
didn't go to state we're not winning
many games terrible first half
he takes off running at halftime towards
the locker room and this is our second
year in the nba
so he is towards the end of the season
because he's starting to play more i'm
starting he's starting
he takes all just sprinting towards the
locker room so we get in there we're
sitting there and the coaches like hey
we got to do this guy do that at gilbert
when you get the ball here
you know you got to do this
hey where gilbert at here's the shower
running
yogurt comes out of the shower
full uniform
shoes and socks
just dripping wet dripping wet it's like
he's like what the [ __ ] you doing
ah coach i had a bad game i have to wash
that off
this guy tends to go in the second half
and scored 30 points in the second half
and he was drenched no he changed his
uniform but it was just the fact they
yeah wash it off you have to wash it off
like he just had bad vibes like i had to
wash this off
wow
but that was just gilbert
that type of guy he just
i had tons of stories about gilbert but
that was just one of those guys that's
super superstitious like that yeah he
just felt like he had to wash it off
what a cute dude i bet the coach is like
what the [ __ ] is going on he did say
that
yeah cause it's like in the thick of it
right i mean literally at halftime we
about to go back outside he's running
down what we need to do and it's
can you imagine hearing the shower
running right now and somebody coming in
right now
with that uniform on dripping wet in a
team meeting
everybody's looking like
that's tight though he came back it
would have sucked if it was still pretty
shitty performance yeah all right i love
it
um okay uh uh how did you combat the
stress or anxiety that come with the
expectations of the mba
you know it's it's so tough but i think
you know after
a certain while you're in the nba you
just kind of block all that stuff off
it's almost like um
it's your safe space when you have so
many things going on and off the floor
you just
you go in that gym do you think it's
because like you understand that
everyone else is literally going through
the same thing with you so it's like
your little your little pack yeah yeah
but some go through more than others um
you know with family problems um
scandals scandals uh you know somebody
stealing money from you somebody's
overspending your money i mean just
constant things but i think
for a lot of us um you know a lot of
guys back then especially my er um
were more guys that came from not much
yeah so they were the first guys in
their family to actually run into real
money yeah you know or not even that
the fact that at 20 years old
i'm i'm 20 years old and you give me
five million dollars a year
wow i never had money like that when i
was supposed to do straight out of
college yeah
you know when you had all that stuff
going on and you know meetings and
business people and this and that once
you're in the court that's your safe
space mm-hmm so
none of that stuff matters it nothing
matters
none of that matters it's that's what
you comfortable doing that's what you
want to do when you got your first big
nice check
what did you buy of the first nice thing
you bought yeah for me yeah yeah it was
my mom's house but for me um you got
your mom's house first yeah oh
what did that feel like that was crazy
that was crazy you know to walk in there
and she liked the house and love it and
oh so you picked out a brand new house
yeah
yeah so it was cool you know
well she picked it out and i walked
through it hey that's what you want cool
okay so she was along with the whole
process it wasn't like those big boats
okay okay that's amazing because i just
i was worried about playing basketball
yeah but for me um
a funny story is crazy i don't know
that's for some reason i've been telling
a lot of stories to
friends and stuff um back then it was a
car company called 310 motoring
um in l.a
oh they're like fix up cars aftermarket
cars okay okay
i bought a a cadillac escalade okay so i
was there because they had just bought
it they put some speakers in it did some
tricked out stuff pus they were putting
rims on it
and so i'm up in the store and i see
this guy comes in he got like five
chains on there diamonds and he got
bracelet diamond wash diamond he had his
glasses had dimes on there like all this
[ __ ] is fake this is this [ __ ] is fake
there's no way in the world somebody's
wearing that much [ __ ] jewelry unless
it's usher or someone so i'm a little
giant or something
so we were talking and and so he's like
oh what you doing and i was like i just
bought it you know my first car like
this is my first car how old are you i'm
20. oh okay
i just bought the escalade man i just
they put some rims on he's like yeah i'm
up here man that's cool i just got a
ferrari rolls royce lamborghini and he
named me like five or six cars
and so i'm talking i'm like who is this
clown like
you know i'm just like who's this dude
so he's talking it's the ladies off man
it's just cool you know he's where
you're from from michigan are you from
alfred michigan too oh this is that
saginaw i'm from grand rapids
i'm floyd mayweather mayweather
oh
this wasn't this is pretty boy floyd
okay not the floyd we know right now
yeah yeah so at the time no you know he
was boxing and winning but nobody really
know who he was yeah and i heard the
name
and so when i think about that moment
first of all all the diamonds were real
yeah yeah
these glasses they were just diamonds
around the room
there's probably worse for his vision
i've never seen any diamonds on one
person in my life and they were all like
like top-notch diners it was unreal but
i it just stick out to me because it was
like my first big purchase and it was
like the you know i meet floyd
mayweather at the same time that's
amazing that's so cool what a cocky dude
i love him
he's in the toys for like traveling like
a duffel bag full of million dollars
yeah he doesn't buy [ __ ] he's just like
i buy where once i'm done
dang that's type
okay funniest prank
uh on another or funniest prank another
teammate did
this is great
that's a great question it goes back to
gilbert like he's like he's a clown like
in nba we said we have nba best friends
like my nba best friend
and so we got drafted we we had the same
agent so we worked out all summer
together and then we get drafted to
golden state together so we like we've
been together like for like eight months
did you know him in college we played
against each other college but we didn't
know each other i see
but we became real good friends like i'm
like gilbert's really a really good
basketball player and i was like in the
front office like hey you got to play
gilbert like he's that good and so we
became friends long story short so all
season long it's rookie hazen they make
us carry backpacks they make us carry
the bags all the stuff like that i love
it but i'm really like down to earth and
i know what my place is so they backed
off me that's all j cool yeah but
gilbert always gave the veteran [ __ ]
like he always
used to mess with him
and so he's asking for it he's just
asking for gilbert sounds like me
he's just asking i'm like
just
do what they say they go back off for
you yeah this is [ __ ] i don't need
to do this so we towards the end of the
season it's our rookie year
and it they got off of me about getting
donuts it was gilbert tash every game
for pre for shoot around he has to bring
donuts in the newspaper
so he got tired of buying it so he you
know he was on a second year i mean um
second round contract so he didn't have
a lot of money so buying donuts every
day was kind of getting expensive for
him
so he came he comes in one day he had
these donuts he got this big ass smile
on his face
and so
he put the donuts down he said jay rich
do not eat the donuts i licked on every
last one
he licked on every last one of them
right
so the veterans get to get a hold of
this that he licked on every donut
so what the better is gonna do they're
gonna get him even worse
so we had this tub it's like this tub up
this high about this wire to put our
laundry in our practice units or the
managers
could watch them after the game
so after the practice the very next day
they fill this tub up with water and ice
like just freezing water and ice
and so practice get over it and all the
veterans go over there and they grab and
gill and they're getting taped and they
taping him up
like a mummy yeah
and they they go they carry them into
this locker
and they dump them into the tub
this tub is deep now it's this high off
the ground from florida to here
oh wow he taped up so he started like
kind of drowning
[Laughter]
so he's going crazy they finally pulled
him out
and he goes ballistic
he goes outside and he's busting people
car doors and windows and stuff
they have to get the management oh wow
okay i said gilbert if you never licked
the donuts we wouldn't have been in this
situation sure that's just gilbert
dude he asked for it he sounds like an
awesome guy
he's a great guy
all right uh what is the most memorable
moment in your basketball career
i feel like you have a ton
i do i have a ton of them um
i think for me just um
the night i got drafted
um
it was just like a dream come true uh i
can remember to this day
i'm sitting there in the draft room i
have my daughter my mom my uncle who's
like my father figure my agent
my coach
uh
stepfather and we just sitting at the
round table in front of the you know the
draft board and the stage and stuff
and i knew i was going like getting
picked like between
three and eight
but i didn't know
and uh when golden state they looking at
me start pointing and i'm literally
kicking my uncle i'm kicking he's like
what's wrong i'm going to go stay i'm
going to go to state
and he's like what you talking about i
said i'm about to get in with the car
and then when
you know commissioner stern um came
across the stage with fitbit golden
state where he's like jason richardson i
just jumped up and he was gave him a big
bear hug
and
my daughter started crying she's like
what's going on all this tension this
camera's here and she was two at the
time
and you know the walk i mean i had the
smile on my face i mean you see all the
pictures like i showed everything
and the thing i can remember about
my suit was way too big
it was like i had this massive suit on
yeah but the story behind the suit long
story short i had a tailored suit and
somehow the guy didn't get the suit he
didn't finish a suit
so
literally hours before the draft i'm
literally running around new york city
trying to find a suit oh i'm going
everywhere and at your height yeah but
it's crazy because i'm not super tall
but i'm not super short so i'm right in
between
where i could fit a regular suit out of
like sacks yeah but my arms are too long
for a second but i can't wear anything
out of big and tall
and so i'm like stuck i'm nearly for two
hours before the draft i'm trying to
find a suit god finally find a suit
and it's big it's literally like
it was like a zoo from like the yeah
yeah yeah yeah everybody's had a big hat
yeah yeah yeah
to this day is the worst picture ever i
gotta fight it you gotta chill but it
was the happiest moment the happiest
moment of my life but that suit was
terrible so what is it like is it a room
full of just uh like a lot of people
right yeah so you have you have this
they invite the fans fans can come and
watch but then they invite
uh the lottery pick which is like the
top 14 players so they they normally go
like the top 16 players
in their family
um they let you sit in front of the
stage and and enjoy the moment you hear
your name get called and they've been
doing that since
78 or 77 or something like that okay
that's when you put the the hat of the
team on you take a picture yeah take a
picture with the commissioner yeah
because i've seen it recently or in the
past few years man those suits are wild
yeah they're getting out of hand now
some people go
nuts they have like glasses and like
they just they go nuts so i'm like don't
feel too bad about your oversized suit i
think it's fine it was bad
all right this one's a dope one okay
what's the atmosphere behind the scenes
when the i believe season especially
around the first round versus the mavs
wow
what was that like that team was you
know by far one of the fun
the funniest and funnier teams i ever
played on we had a group of full of like
degeneres on it
oh that's fun seriously and it was so
fun because
you know
my case was
i got numbers but i played on the bad
team and then we had stephen jackson who
had the big brawl um al harrington they
were saying washed up baron davis
they're saying
uh he was injured prone
uh matt barnes was a journeyman and we
just bonded together and but the thing
was it was like
we partied
we had to party that was our thing we
like we'll go out party wake up the next
day play the game and go to the
wow i don't know how we did that
you're super young i was gonna let you
know to this day my name is don julio
that's how bad it was
to this day they called me the dawn
because i used to drink don julio every
time we went out and we got guys on team
one one guy named andres bigens but they
call him goose because he drink a lot of
grey goose
but that was just the team and that
atmosphere those guys man it was like it
was so fun yeah because
we just didn't care we were going out
there and we was go play hard have fun
enjoy each other and just try to whoop
your ass and we did that a lot and um
it's so important because
we did it in a short period of span like
we we had to win like i think it was
like 18 out of 26 games and that was
like unheard of and we just caught fire
and it just the rest is history man
that's awesome
ah that is freaking awesome um there's a
ton of of that though we believe
everyone's there's another one here uh
yo jay rich uh warriors fan here
obviously dude uh uh who would win in
seven game series uh we believe team
versus the 2015 warriors uh yeah 2015
warriors 2015 worries that's that's hard
man because it's two different styles of
basketball
um
i i get that question a lot it's it's so
hard to compare the errors um
i mean they had a lot of great players
on that team i think that was kevin
durant was on that team yeah
i mean you got kevin durant that's hard
i mean it was just him alone yeah you
had stuff and then you had clay
but we had a good group of guys too i
mean we we play
you know knock down defense you know
stephen jackson and matt barnes and
um phrase i mean it's hard it is it is
it's a hard one okay
uh favorite memory with warriors besides
beating dallas first round
um
um probably
all-star games um i bet those are really
fun they were fun but um the second year
i went the first year myself it was just
me in the dunk contest and now playing
the rookie sophomore challenge game but
then the next year
um is that the one you won
i won the first dunk contest but then i
went the next year for the dunk contest
but two of my teammates which
was gilbert arenas and troy murphy we
all had the same agent we all hung out
you know two years prior in l.a working
out together we all got drafted to go
stay together we all had an agent
they played in the sophomore game with
me so it was pretty cool you know it was
a good moment for like the bay area like
this is the future of the bay area
that's cool and it was cool that you
know gilbert he went out there and
scored like 35 points broke the record
for most points in the game at the time
troy had a good game i had a good game
and
it was just cool that we were all
friends we were all from the bay um you
know golden state and jordan together
area so that's probably my my second
favorite moment out there we believe
that sounds tight
um okay biggest rivalry and motivation
so biggest rivalry first
i don't think it was a necessary rivalry
um i feel like you're too nice or even a
one-sided rivalry you know sometimes
there's like a guy that just
out for you and you're like why are you
out for me
no i just i really got up for a play
against kobe uh i don't think it was the
same way with him
[Laughter]
um
in the nba there's not really a lot of
rivalries going on there's just
you play against so many great guys at
the time you just always want to play
your best against the best ones so yeah
for me it was always when i played kobe
i always wanted to play my best because
it's kobe he's winning everything he's
like that's the guy yeah yeah so
anytime i play against kobe is like yeah
i'm ready for them yeah that's a good
guy to measure against yeah what about
growing up did you have like a favorite
basketball player and you're like i like
his style or i like what he's about yeah
my favorite basketball player was
dominique wilkins for atlanta hawks
jumper i mean
that's probably why i can't jump off of
one leg because of him
because everything he did was two foot
yeah i just emulated him since i was a
kid like so
everything he did i could do because i
just love the way he plays so
that was my favorite player oh i see
yeah you're nasty on the court though
you're aggressive
um okay uh favorite player to play
against
and any player that reminds you of
yourself now currently in the league
well favorite player is just kobe still
i just i just always loved playing
against him he was just
it was just it brought something out of
me yeah what it was it just brought
somebody cause he's just such a
competitor he was such a competitor oh
man he's just such a better um
a player right now
not i don't know
it could be so different now too
it's different because the the thing is
these guys are literally better they're
more skilled than i was
it is
i can dribble and shoot like these guys
can i mean i worked on it but these guys
are so skilled
um
there's nobody like that anymore because
they could do everything right would you
say this era of basketball
is generally better than the last like
in every era it keeps getting better
yeah because we had certain guys that
only do certain things like we had like
a bruce wayne that was just basically
defense
um later became a shooter um
we had guys like jason kidd that was
just the point guard but these guys you
know we got you know jokic at seven feet
tall he's he plays point guard
or you look at the warriors they don't
really have a center and draymond's play
point guard sometimes so
these guys are definitely more skilled
than us but i think my error was
definitely more tougher than them oh i
see
um there are some of those questions in
two uh when was the first time that you
dunked a basketball
the first time i dunked the basketball
was going into the ninth grade um i was
at a park in my my hometown i was by
myself and i'm just out there shooting
messing around and
i was like maybe i could dunk let me see
and i just go out there and i boom i was
like
nobody saw it i took off running
seriously i took off running into my
grandmother's house which is like a half
a mile away
dead sprint wow
i just dog
and everybody's like yeah right
i'll just dunk i literally dragged the
whole family oh that's awesome my mother
mother
uncle it's like 20 people at the park
and i'm just out there doing they're
like okay he could dunk
that is so sick i love that they're like
we don't buy it yeah let's go
have you tried dunking up to that point
like seventh eighth grade did you try
touching the rim or anything no it just
came out of nowhere i never tried any of
that you never so you never even like
had the you know most people have a
progression i could touch the net yeah
now i could touch the backboard i could
touch the rim
he's just like i want to go try it whoa
he's like oh [ __ ] that's crazy all right
what is it like becoming so famous what
was the change like
i don't think i'm famous i'm gonna be
honest with you i i'm just a level guy i
never saw myself as uh like so your life
didn't change at all you felt no i
seriously did i i didn't feel the
difference because what about even with
like the bay area love like during that
era do you think you walk down the
streets of like san francisco because
i'm the type of person like
what's up man how you doing let's talk
and i see a lot of guys um
that weren't like that so for me it
didn't really affect me like fame really
wasn't important to me that's i didn't
play basketball to be fair be famous i
see so that's you know at the heyday of
me being in a in golden state
i still didn't feel like i was famous
because i would go to places some people
wouldn't go to like at the time a lot of
people didn't go down to jacqueline
square i was down there
a lot of people wouldn't go to certain
malls i went to them a lot of people
didn't go and study nightclubs i went to
them but were you like signing
autographs and stuff and that never was
like dang this person wants my autograph
well
you know i did it a little bit in
college um and it never bothered me to
this day if people see me don't take a
picture or ask for autograph it never
bothers me the only time i have a
problem is when i'm with my kids
and even then i'll still do it but when
this assessment is constant is constant
they're older now they understand it but
when they were like younger like your
son age yeah
i would do a few and then i'm like hey
man i just want to because i didn't have
much time my kids i'm always traveling
yeah so that's the only time where i
would normally say well i'm with my
family i want my son you know it's
i could talk to you for a little bit but
this is his time yeah but other than
that you come up to me i was talking to
you signing autographs and it didn't
bother me you're too humble man he's
like i'm not famous but it got to the
point where there were so many people
i had to turn them away
all right
just a little bit
all right what is your favorite pair of
shoes to play in
any kobe's oh really
cope so no no jordans no jordan's i love
jordan's collecting george or where
jordan's yeah george i bought fire the
worst shoes to play basketball
and i have flat feet so it doesn't work
flat shoes with flat feet uh hurt your
feet all the time yeah this guy right
here too i love that i have all the
jordans there is but i would i never
played a day of basketball in jordan's
ever so kobe's favorites kobe's yeah so
i started off wearing reebok and then i
went to a chinese shoe company called
peak and then
the later part of my career
the kobe's was the most comfortable shoe
and so now when i go play basketball or
you know i train some of these kids they
ask me come train my pain giannis
because they're the closest thing to
kobe's because they stopped making
kobe's but then they came home and said
that she signed the deal back with nike
so thank you vanessa yeah i just saw
that the other day right yeah that's so
cool because everybody loved the kobe
yeah
they're a great shoe have you ever tried
the gilbert arenas did you like those
i'm not wearing those shirts
it was a great deal i mean his shoes
were they were pretty cool but um i just
never wore adidas i just did a nike guy
oh yeah they were i think probably the
most comfortable basketball chevrolet
really and i have flat feet too really
and like i'm pretty heavy for my height
so like it those were like the shoes
that i never really got shin splints in
really yeah so i always liked them i
always felt like adidas were heavy they
were kind of heavy but they had like the
enough padding for stomping around that
it felt good wow he's also really dense
like his bones are heavy yeah i have
heavy bones oh you might want to try
those gilbert arenas
he's like hell no
all the time why you just fall down i
said heavy bones yeah when he's in the
pool he just sinks yeah me too i can't
float yeah if i go in the pool and i
hold my breath
i just
all right um do you feel robbed of not
getting your third slam dunk
championship no i don't at all
because
um
honestly the third dunk contest i didn't
want to do it mm-hmm i was
against it nba called me all this time
like yo i don't want to do it no more
so electric it was so sad yeah it was
i didn't want to be labeled a dunker
because
you know and that's all i was known for
because we weren't on tv we're getting
our ass kicked
the only time people saw me was the dunk
contest so i didn't want that just to be
who i am because i worked so hard on my
game every year yeah i just didn't want
to be a dunker so i tell people all the
time when i get asked this question if
you go back and watch that third dunk
contest
and watch the the first two my energy
and that third one is like i don't want
to [ __ ] be here
and i did a spectacular dunk
like i never practiced that dunk
throwing it off the backboard and taking
between the legs i never practiced that
dunk but i knew i could do it because of
my drilling but after i did the dunk
everybody's going crazy i'm like yeah
because i didn't want to be there
i was like
and then so the last dunk or that dunk
contest
um fred jones did a dunk and it was
pretty simple but all i had to do was no
disrespect all i had to do was something
easy yeah
i literally missed the dunk on purpose i
tried to do a
360 and try to put my arm in the room if
i did a regular 360 i win the dunk
contest yeah i was like well you might
as well go out with a bang because i
don't want to win it anyways yeah yeah
and it's just my energy just wasn't
there because i didn't want to do it and
then i was dealing with the fact that my
stepfather was
sick at the time and he was you know in
his final stages of life
and i couldn't really go home i went
home for a day yeah flo flew out that
scene i on the private plane to get back
to l.a so i went from oakland all the
way to michigan wow stayed a few hours
with him and come back just for the dunk
contest so wow my energy was i see off
it was so off and when i watch i go back
and watch that dunk i'm like damn that
was a good ass dunk cause
zion williams just did it he threw it
off the backboard he did the dunk and
somebody's like oh jason richardson did
it better and then when i looked at it i
was like damn that was pretty cool but
then
i did and i was like huh yeah yeah yeah
thank you man i appreciate it yeah you
could just say oh my energy just wasn't
there and the other two contests were
screaming ah
yeah that's fair that's fair okay so
kind of this leads into this question
then would you rather be the best dunker
the best shooter in the world best
shooter by far like for me duncan was
just easy that's what i did all my life
and um i really took pride of becoming a
shooter and so
me leaving the nba um
i think i was 12th at the time when i
retired that was like a big
accomplishment because i couldn't shoot
the ball that is amazing so it just
showed my dedication my hard work to to
work on my my craft yeah because you
said in your 20s you couldn't shoot for
[ __ ] you were [ __ ] yeah you were sure
you were telling us you were shooting
you were trying to make a thousand bucks
yeah
yeah i mean it was just crazy because
like when i was in college they would
tell me like i had other friends at
other schools and they were telling me
the scholar report was don't guard jason
outside of 10 feet oh that's rough
i'm literally catching the ball the room
is right here at the camera and like the
guy is standing right there and like i
was like i'm gonna get the rebound don't
worry
what an [ __ ] but they say if he get a
foot in the paint you're gonna be on
sports center and so when i found out
i'll say okay i got to work on my
shooting yeah that does put a fire under
your ass for sure it's so disrespectful
it's so disrespectful
to guys in the nba especially how
skilled these guys when that stuff goes
on i mean like that is so disrespectful
it is it is
uh do you think the nba is easier to get
into these days
um this day and age compared to your era
i i think it's easier because the guys
are seeing more um because of all the
the social media stuff going on
but i think it's actually harder because
these guys are so skilled they are very
skilled um i couldn't imagine my erect
guarding somebody like
giannis
he's seven feet eight
and then dribble the ball can shoot it
dunk on you euro
um to chase somebody around like steph
curry even though we had ray allen but
you know ray allen is only shooting like
maybe four or five three stuff and
shooting 12 threes a game
so it's just it's just these guys are so
much more skilled in my era i think it's
it's actually harder this error than
mine do you think is it um so it's
because of the social media there is
more access to information um but do you
think it's it's a lot more not saturated
i don't want to say it's saturated but
there's just a lot more competition yeah
it's a lot more competition um i think
the difference from my era it goes back
to these kids they play a lot so much
that they too friendly with each other
like so
most of these kids um they might have
played au ball since the sixth grade
against each other and
they went to the same high school or
different high schools or they just it's
too friendly so when they get on the
court it's like i don't really want to
touch you ah my area i'm putting my bow
in your damn neck yeah i'm gonna follow
the [ __ ] off you yeah yeah yeah these
kids like i'm not gonna really file you
you're my friend still yeah it's like
the software yeah just they're too
friendly with each other yeah what is
that it's weird we like like the dirty
celtics and stuff and all their little
antics and stuff yeah that's what made
it exciting you turn it on to see who's
gonna get in the fight or damn near a
fight because they would go i mean they
was playing hard like it was really
that game really mattered from the win
yeah i think it was also probably closer
to like um like like everyone was
playing more street ball back in the day
too yeah yeah and it wasn't so like high
tech in the gym and like now you have
your nutritionists and all this stuff
these days if you play a pickup game in
the gym people will call like fouls too
i'm like i'm like fouls was if you call
the foul on like a pickup game you're
being a little [ __ ] you know
but now people call fouls you're like
what the hell this is crazy but it's
just not kids just going into the gym or
just playing yeah like you said it just
everything is trained everything is
it got to be orchestrated you just can't
just go in there and just play anymore
so that takes away from that
competitiveness yeah y'all being too
soft
[Laughter]
um hardest player to guard
tracy mcgrady
hardest player for me to guard i don't
know what it was
but every time i played him he gave me
30 points it was like tracy mcgrady just
put 30 points down he's scoring 30 on
jason tonight damn he was just
i don't know it was just he was just so
wiry and long
and he could just shoot the ball he
could post you up
he could drive past you he'd go dunk on
you i just had a hard time guarding him
damn
um okay so you did talk about steven
jackson a little bit how how was it like
uh playing with him
ultimate teammates
oh my gosh he had your back for
everything
everything
he didn't matter what like personal life
whatever it was i mean i know if i if i
got filed hard
before i even got up and he was in there
somebody's face
oh that's tough he's just a he's a loyal
guy um
and he just ride with you it's that's
just who he is that's the type of person
he is so you know he was like one of my
you know favorite team well everybody on
that we believe team
we had a special bond so
we all had each other back but that guy
right there man he's one of the loyals
guys i know that's so sick i love it do
you guys have like um
because i'm sure everyone's busy but
do you guys have like a specific thing
you guys do once a year to kind of get
all the guys back together to hang out
or like family events or anything no i
think um
we we haven't done anything in a few
years we got together i think we had it
was in uh a warriors game but we haven't
done nothing in a while but i know steve
and matt has that podcast and they've
been talking about it for years getting
us all on there so oh
it's just a matter of time when they
could put it together i know they got
some
better high profile guests than
us
that's funny
that's one of the things that like when
we're hiring people for our team
bart always has to be like he has to ask
if they play basketball because he feels
like there's something
about the person that that has played on
a basketball team that they're going to
bring this team loyalty or camaraderie
um or or just the court iq of like
having everyone's back yeah um
that that he's just like if you've
played basketball you're probably gonna
be good on our in our company yeah like
um
i suck at basketball
a lot
but like a lot like a lot
but i understand the dynamic of it so if
we got like two people applying for the
same job
and i'm like kind of stuck in between
and one person has played basketball in
a team
even if it's like middle school but and
they played organized ball right i will
always go with them because i think
basketball is one of those rare sports
where one
you can shine as a team so you
understand teamwork but two you could
also be a star by yourself so if you
need to carry the torch by yourself you
can
and there are it's also one of the uh
sports where
you can wear one hat but you sometimes
have to wear another hat right and you
have to be okay with it and not go
that's not my job you know so it's one
of those where i'm like
in that sport it teaches you so many
lessons
that when i
see like two applicants i'm okay this
guy understands that sometimes this guy
he's hired to be a shooter but if he
needs to get a rebound
he he won't go well that's not my job i
never looked at it like that that is i'm
gonna have to use that seriously
seriously because it is true because in
in basketball you know one night you
might be the scorer yeah the next night
you might be the guy that had to defend
somebody so you know how to do multiple
things
i never looked at it like that oh i
wanted to use that yeah it's dope don't
copy right there yet
because i was bad so i sat on the
bleachers i watched a lot of what was
going on
no but yeah when he breaks it down right
you're just like holy [ __ ] that's
literally so applicable to life
yeah like in the friend circle in in
business like in in everything because
you need the team to win right
um because you know it's like anywhere
from like 60 to 100 points divided by
like the main five people yeah but
sometimes one person can win the game by
themselves too which is so rare in any
other sport you know like you got guys
what's the record like there's people
have made like 70 points or something
yeah yeah it's like
so it's just so rare where like
sometimes if you're in a team
environment
sometimes that one person will
accomplish the mission by themselves
even though it's a team mission and i
just understanding that dynamic and it's
possible it's i just only see it in
basketball that is dope yeah i'm about
to be serious
i'm gonna steal it out for you guys
any t-shirts or anything like that but
go ahead i'll take you that approach
that is awesome thinking i never thought
it would be like that no take it it's
yours
uh okay last question we'll make it a
fun one all right uh what is your
favorite dessert and where do you get it
from
i have like a sugar fetish i'd love to
me too i can go eat a teaspoon of sugar
right now
oh like that just straight up no i won't
do it but that's how much i like sugar
you don't even got to put cinnamon or
honey i won't do it
i just love sugar i saw like a whole lot
so you're setting it up that you're like
it's like trash taste buds so you're
just gonna eat anything with sugar
anything that has sugar in it and
especially if it's gummy oh my gosh i am
a sucker for like gummy bears oh
so i i like anything that has sugar do
you like sour belts you like this i like
anything gummy okay but dessert
do you like pastries and stuff too i
like anything with sugar in it okay yeah
just see everything i'm breathing
especially if it's good i am gonna like
kill it i'm gonna bring a bunch of stuff
yeah i did that dude i was like i gained
like five pounds right
i'm trying to stay trying to cut the
sugar off man i'm old i can't process it
like i used to you're that old we're
like really close to age i think you're
like a year older than us a year a year
or two yeah are you 82
81 yeah we're 83 he's 84. yeah yeah
we're not that old you're in your 30s
we're not it changes when you turn 40.
okay it changes all right all right i'll
give it to you well we'll give you half
of the desserts okay
well thank you so much for being here
you're so fun you're super humble like
thank you you're you're awesome you're
awesome and i hope that everyone else
just sees the awesomeness that we see
i'm sure they already do but thank you
so much for watching anything else you
want to say nope yep he never does cool
we'll catch you next time thank you
bye-bye
cool
thank you i was thinking like
two hours what i'm gonna do for two
hours this is like i didn't even know it
was two hours this is awesome